merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur arnaud viala pour
le groupe l'est républicain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
les chiffres du chômage de septembre
cette semaine monsieur le premier
ministre vous lave le cerveau et vous
font oublier que des millions de
français sont et restent des chômeurs de
longue durée
vous n'êtes pas dans la même galaxie que
les français vous annoncer la sortie de
crise la reprise de la croissance alors
que notre tissu économique tout entier
crie son inquiétude
vous n'êtes pas dans la même galaxie que
les entrepreneurs de france
parler de réduction des déficits publics
de baisse de la fiscalité et les élus
locaux
atterré doivent assumer les charges et
que vous délester sur eux
vous n'êtes pas dans la même galaxie que
les élus de france
vous voulez que la france accueille des
migrants et partout des français comme
chez moi un matin ce réveil est ahuri en
découvrant qu'un individu condamné à
mort par la justice de notre pays est
hébergé dans un hôtel à deux pas de chez
eux
vous n'êtes pas dans la même galaxie que
nos compatriotes aux agriculteurs de
france qui crient leur désespoir vous
donner comme seule solution la
télétransmission de razac
d'administratifs dimanche dernier pour
la deuxième fois en un angle j'ai dû
faire face au suicide d'une exploitante
agricole de ma commune
vous n'êtes pas dans la même galaxie que
les agriculteurs de france
d'après vous je cite le pouvoir d'achat
des français n'a jamais autant augmenté
venez donc tenir ces propos aux
retraités aux jeunes ménages d'actifs de
france
vous n'êtes pas la même galaxie que nos
concitoyennes ce sentiment de rupture
totale entre notre peuple et vous ses
dirigeants
tout le monde le perçoit sauf vous et je
voudrais savoir monsieur le premier
ministre si vous pensez rester enfermé
dans vos certitudes
au risque de vous retrouver à votre
fenêtre de séjour et marie antoinette à
dire aux français que s'ils n'ont pas de
pain ils n'ont qu'à manger de la brioche
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre la
présidente monsieur le monsieur le
député je ne sais pas si nous sommes
dans la même galaxie à vous écouter
j'en doute mais en tout cas je sais que
nous sommes dans le même pays la france
et sert à rien d'être excessif les
ruptures les fractures territoriales et
sociales les attendent les exigences les
peurs de nos compatriotes de nos
concitoyens malheureusement nous les
connaissons elles ne sont pas nouvelles
elles viennent depuis longtemps il sert
à rien d'ailleurs de les commenter
seulement et de jouer avec et par
ailleurs de tout mélanger parce que
c'est précisément
monsieur le député pardon de vous le
dire ainsi celle amalgame c'est le
mélange des problèmes économiques
sociaux du chômage de ce que peuvent
ressentir les agriculteurs les ouvriers
de ce que peut ressentir une partie de
notre jeunesse avec des problèmes liés à
la sécurité ou à la lutte contre le
terrorisme ou à l'accueil des réfugiés
par cet amalgame c'est vous mêmes
d'ailleurs monsieur le député qui est
aggravée ces fractures et les fractures
entre les responsables publics est le
peuple c'est par l'excès des propos
parce que tout simplement les français
considèrent que depuis des années et la
question m'a été encore posé tout à
l'heure comme hier depuis des années
nous sommes habitués à vivre avec un
chômage de masse avec un niveau de
déficit
insupportable et avec un niveau de
fiscalité nationale ou locale que
beaucoup de français ne peuvent pas
supporter et l'action de mon
gouvernement et je le dit modestement
c'est de s'attaquer précisément au
niveau de déficit qu'ils sont trop
élevés il baisse à l'endettement du pays
qui n'est pas supportable pour les
années qui viennent nous nous attaquons
au chômage chacun peut regarder les
chiffres
comme ils sont et nous faisons avec ma
gamelle comme rick dans la durée mais
moi je me réjouis d'ailleurs l'un
d'entre vous monsieur mariton l'a fait
hier quand le chômage baisse est une
bonne chose
en tout cas pour ceux qui retrouvent un
emploi plutôt que d'en faire un sujet de
polémique
nous attaquons aux inégalités
territoriales urbaines et rurales nous
attaquons aux inégalités dans l'école
qui n'a jamais été votre priorité
alors moi aussi monsieur le député
je pourrais parfaitement vous renvoyez
les responsabilités qui sont les vôtres
mais parce que précisément je pense que
l'état du pays
la crise économique sociale et morale
que nous vivons depuis les années
nécessite de la hauteur de vue de
l'engagement et du rassemblement
je ne vous répondrai pas ainsi et je
vous demanderais tout simplement de
revenir dans la bonne galaxy merci j'ai
prévu